MARK MIRCHANDANI: Welcome
to the second part
of our top 10 questions
for customer engineers.
Let's jump right into it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Question number six, how
does Google secure my data?
CORI PEELE: We encrypt
at rest and in transit.
Our infrastructure doesn't
rely on any single technology
to make it secure.
We've designed security
of our infrastructure
in layers that builds upon
each other from the physical
security of the data
centers to these security
protections in our
hardware and software
to the processes we use to
support operational security.
This layered protection
creates strong security
as a foundation for
everything we do.
Data stored on
our infrastructure
is automatically encrypted
at rest by default
and distributed for
availability and reliability.
We also support
customer-managed encryption keys
using Cloud QMS and
customer-supplied encryption
keys.
Communication over the
internet to our cloud services
are encrypted.
The scale of our
infrastructure allows
us to absorb many denial
of service attacks,
and we have multiple layers of
protection that further reduce
the risk of any DDoS impact.
Finally, our operations team
detects threats and responds
to incidents around the clock.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Security is important,
and applications are
often business-critical
to our customers, so
they need to be confident
that Google Cloud is
reliable and scalable.
Question number
seven-- is Google
ready for the enterprise?
YURI GRINSHTEYN: That
is a great question
that every customer
should be asking,
and we got lots of customers
to answer that one for us.
You can read what they have
to say about this by going
to cloud.google.com/customers.
You'll see that folks from
Charles Schwab and the Chicago
Department of Transportation
to Johnson and Johnson
and the National
Institute on Aging
have all decided that Google
Cloud is reliable, scalable,
and secure enough for them.
Analysts agree with them.
For example, Forrester
just named Google Cloud
a leader in their Public
Cloud Platform Native Security
Report.
This all just goes to show
our combination of world class
infrastructure, research
and thought leadership,
and folks just like these
customer engineers next to me
all add up to making
Google Cloud the place
to run enterprise workloads.
CORI PEELE: That sure
makes us feel better
about running business-critical
applications on GCP.
But on to question eight--
how do I control my cloud costs?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
We have many ways
to help you estimate
and control your costs.
You're always able to use
the pricing calculator
to help estimate what your
workload costs might look
like once you're on the cloud.
Once you're up and running,
your instances and services
can be labeled to help
organize your resources.
Building data can be
exported to BigQuery in order
to review and analyze what
you're spending in case
the default bills aren't
descriptive enough.
Plus, you can set up
budgets and alerting
from your cloud console to
warn you well ahead of time
before you spend your budget.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Oh,
I dropped my contacts.
CORI PEELE: Oh, we'll help.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Oh, we'll help you.
NICK ORLOVE: And we're back.
Let's see.
Where were we?
That's right--
question number nine.
What is a managed service, and
what problems does it solve?
IVAN RAMIREZ: Well,
a managed service
is exactly what it
says on the box.
It's a set of
services or products
where Google takes care of
the upkeep and maintenance.
Since its inception, Google
has put a strong focus
on marrying open
source technologies
with fully managed services.
While we focus on
the maintenance,
you get the product
that truly stands out,
allowing you to
refocus your engineer's
time from a
maintenance-centric approach
to a feature-focused strategy
that ensures your time
and effort are being
spent on the things that
will set your application and
company apart from the rest.
A good example of
this no-ops approach
is best shown when we
discuss the concept
of [? flat ?] migrations.
With Google Cloud, we
seamlessly migrate your instance
to another machine through
Google's hardware maintenance
events so that you don't
suffer any downtime.
Most of our users
don't even notice.
NICK ORLOVE: Finally--
drumroll, please--
question number 10.
What makes GCP special?
STEPHANIE WONG:
Well, us, of course.
And in addition,
Google Cloud Platform
differs in a variety of ways,
including our security model,
which is an end-to-end
process built
over 15 years of experience
keeping our customers
safe on Google apps like Gmail.
We offer a global network.
Our network backbone
has thousands
of miles of
fiberoptic cable using
advanced software-defined
networking and Edge
caches globally to deliver
fast, consistent performance.
We also live and
breathe big data.
We contributed to innovations
like MapReduce, Bigtable,
and Dremel, and new frameworks
for data warehousing
and machine learning, even batch
and real time data processing.
Our solutions are
serverless, and they
let you take advantage
of the years of research
that we've done.
And we offer Compute Engine
billing by the second,
so you don't have to
pay for compute minutes
that you don't use.
And of course, we are
environmentally friendly,
and our data centers run on half
of the energy of a typical data
center.
In 2017, we purchased
100% renewable energy
to match our consumption
for our global operations.
IVAN RAMIREZ:
Thanks for watching,
and make sure to like,
comment, and subscribe below.
STEPHANIE WONG: And if you'd
like to get in contact with us,
click on the link
in the description.
[MUSIC PLAYING]